c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir la côte d'ivoire qui a à
nouveau vice président il s'agit de
tiémoko meyliet koné ancien gouverneur
de la banque centrale des états
d'afrique de l'ouest il a été nommé par
le président alassane ouattara lors
d'une allocution au parlement à
yamoussoukro nous serons dans la
capitale politique du pays dans un
vestiaire ça commence mal pour la ccps
la cour pénal spécial censé juger les
crimes commis en centrafrique depuis
2003 à peine l'audience ouverte elle a
été reportée au 25 avril prochain cette
cour donné comme exemple par des lourds
de nombreuses ong pour refaire
pourrait-elle faire son travail nous
serons nous poserons la question
abdoulaye diarra chercheur à amnesty
international spécialiste de la
centrafrique
et à la fin de ce journal nous irons en
tunisie vous verrez que cette année les
réalisateurs ont innové pour les séries
du ramadan les thèmes choisis ne sont
pas classique nos correspondants à tunis
se sont rendus sur des plateaux de
tournage reportage à suivre
tiémoko meyliet tu connais c'est le nom
du nouveau vice président ivoirien la
nomination de l'ancien gouverneur de la
bceao a été annoncée par le président
alassane ouattara lors d'une allocution
au parlement yamoussoukro les précisions
de notre envoyé spécial dans la capitale
politique annan ferdjani avec samuel
bernard président a en effet dévoilé
l'identité du prochain vice président
qui n'est autre que l'actuel gouverneur
de la bceao tiémoko meyliet koné tiémoko
koné qui a occupé des postes au sein du
gouvernement tant sous laurent gbagbo
que sous alassane ouattara un homme qui
selon le président possède les qualités
personnelles et professionnelles
nécessaires pour devenir le numéro deux
ivoiriens
nous avons demandé à des députés s'il
s'agissait pour alassane ouattara de
préparer un nouveau dauphin pour lui
succéder une question qu'ils ont préféré
éluder
parce que
nul ne peut prévoir je vous assure une
le voile je pense pour l'état actuel des
choses il faut les tenir que le
président de la république sem alassane
ouattra le vice présidence et timoko on
va pas aller sous la casaque de faim
nous en tant qu'opposition ce qui vous
intéresse celle que nous revenons à une
situation de stabilité politique normale
l'analyste politique sylvain n'guessan
lui s'autorise à interpréter cette
annonce selon lui cette nomination en
congrès est une façon pour le président
ouattara de rappeler qu'il est toujours
aux commandes et de s'octroyer une
option supplémentaire en vue de
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 25
et puis sachez que cette prise de parole
est intervenue une semaine après la
démission du premier ministre patrick
achi patrick achi qui a été reconduit et
chargée de nommer un nouveau
gouvernement dans les prochains jours
une équipe réduite on vous parle à
présent de ce procès sans précédent en
centrafrique la cour pénale spéciale la
cps un tribunal hybride composée de
magistrats nationaux et internationaux a
ouvert son premier procès ce mardi à
bangui objectifs jugés et les crimes de
guerre et crimes contre l'humanité
commis depuis janvier 2003 l'initiative
est unique mais à peine l'audience
ouverte ce mardi elle a été reportée
pour en parler nous sommes en direct de
dakar avec abdoulaye diarra chercheur à
amnesty international spécialiste de la
centrafrique bonsoir monsieur tout
d'abord est ce que ce report d'audience
en raison de l'absence des avocats de la
défense qui ont fait défection à la
dernière minute et signes de fragilité
du tribunal oui bon soit effectivement
depuis ce week-end il y avait des
rumeurs
autour de la participation
eva boca de la dépense donc qui sont
inscrits au niveau
du conte spéciale des avocats et qui
sont chargés d'assister les insultes et
les victimes et s'est porté notamment
sur la question de l'horaire est donc le
fait que aujourd'hui
premier procès devant la cour pénale
spéciale un procès qui a tendu par les
victimes mais également par toute la
population centrafricaine et plus se
tenir témoigne malheureusement des
difficultés auxquelles ce mécanisme
hybride fait face depuis de nombreuses
années alors de nombreux observateurs
saluent le fait que ce procès sur les
crimes commis en centrafrique se déroule
en centrafrique
mais n'est ce pas un risque lorsque l'on
sait que la situation est instable et
qu'il y a encore des affrontements dans
le pays
au café la situation est encore à table
et
l'instabilité qui a redémarré en
décembre 2001 continue de faire des
victimes avec toujours des exactions
commises par toutes les parties au
conflit et donc il est vrai que il ya eu
une importance pour aujourd'hui les
victimes mais également toute la société
civile pour que des procès puisse se
tenir et au sein de la cour des
mécanismes sont prévus justement pour la
protection des témoins des victimes donc
nous pouvons penser que les mesures
nécessaires ont été prises afin de
garantir la protection de tous les
participants et prospère alors ce procès
ne risque-t-il pas d'être ralentie par
le pouvoir politique je pense à à
l'arrestation par des policiers de la
cps du ministre de l'élevage et l'ex
chef rebelle hassan booba soupçonnés
d'être responsables de massacres en 2018
il a finalement été exfiltré de sa
prison il a retrouvé son poste et a même
été décoré par le président le tribunal
pourrait t'il vraiment fonctionné
normalement ou est ce qu'ils disent
qu'il ya voir entrave à la justice
nous avons publié
son dernier briefing justement qui
traitait de cette question avec des
difficultés auxquelles ses pairs des
pâtes et les entraves politiques font
partie de cette difficulté là il est
vrai que l'arrestation est ce que la cps
à la qualité d'évasion
ministre a pu porter un coup à la
crédibilité de la pop et la spéciale
mais il faut ça lui comme l'ouverture de
son premier procès rappeler également
qu'il ya d'autres affaires qui sont en
attente devant cette cour et espérer que
nous 25 dates emprise et d autre chose
que ce procès puisse aller de l'avant et
qu'il appelle tout repose également
parce qu'il ya une vraie attente dans la
société un centre africaine pour que la
justice puisse passer et que la
réconciliation au piège merci beaucoup
abdoulaye diarra chercheur à amnesty
international et spécialiste de la
centrafrique merci pour votre décryptage
le sénégal va connaître une pénurie de
kérosène la société en charge
d'approvisionner les avions a informé
l'aéroport international blaise diagne
qu'à partir de demain le carburant sera
indisponible pour au moins deux semaines
une indisponibilité qui n'affectera pas
les compagnies qui n'affectera que les
compagnies étrangères pourquoi cette
pénurie plus de détails avec notre
correspondant à dakar et linda
c'est à travers une lettre adressée au
directeur de l'aéroport international
blaise diagne de dakar le plus gras
terre pour du sénégal que le fournisseur
en kérosène de l'air pur a informé de
l'indisponibilité du carburant à partir
de ce mercredi 20 avril à partir de 12
heures à l'air pur n'a pas tardé à
réagir à travers un communiqué rendu
public ce lundi les formes que cette
situation est due à une conjoncture
internationale défavorable avec la
production d'hydrocarbures perturber un
peu partout dans le monde ah les
compagnies aériennes sont ainsi priés de
prendre toutes leurs dispositions pour
transporter assez de carburant à même
d'assurer leur vol retour à partir de
l'aéroport de dakar selon nos
informations le sénégal qui dispose d'un
stock de kérosène de plus de deux
millions huit cent mille litres de
carburant à réserver ce stock
principalement ou à la compagnie
nationale air sénégal international mais
également aux vols militaires à
l'aéroport international blaise diagne
de dakar à informe tout de même que des
dérogations pourraient être accordées
aux compagnies aériennes se trouvant
dans certaines contraintes
opérationnelles
le burkina faso qui avance un plan de
réinsertion des djihadistes repentis
lors d'une conférence de presse hiro
boli ministre d'état a détaillé ce plan
qui prévoit la mise en place des comités
locaux de dialogue avec les terroristes
écoutez
si ces joueurs de la rue viennent nous
allons leur proposer de les réinsérer
dans la société à travers des activités
professionnelles par exemple si vous
souhaitez
le faire ce que vous désirez savoir
l'élevage on va trouver le moyen de vous
accompagner pour que vous puissiez
démarrer une activité de ce genre si
vous souhaitez pas de la ville culture
ce sera pareil que ce soit dans les
localités concernées ou ailleurs le
gouvernement tour allait la possibilité
nous permettre de le plan mines
activités normales et de vous des
parties de la violence
les feuilletons du ramadan un véritable
rituel dans le monde musulman tunisie
chaque année son lot de série qui
accompagnent les fidèles lors de la
rupture du jeûne cette année les séries
n'ont pas toutes des thématiques légère
comme nous le montre ce reportage de nos
correspondants à tunis lilia blasé
indique libye
le tournage avait commencé bien avant le
début du mois de ramadan objectif faire
en sorte que la deuxième saison du
feuilleton le gars soit diffusée pendant
le mois sacré loin des thématiques
habituelles abordés pendant le mois de
jeûne alga met en lumière la
problématique de l'immigration
clandestine
un sujet qui fait écho chez les jeunes
tunisiens
nous savons que les tunisiens regardent
beaucoup la télévision pendant le
ramadan donc cela nous encourage à
parler de tels sujets à créer le débat
un gars parlent d'un phénomène que l'on
connaît tous mais que beaucoup de gens
voient comme juste un groupe de jeunes
qui part sur des bateaux de fortune et
qui risquent leur vie nous nous
interrogeons les motivations de ces
migrants et les causes de leur départ
cette liberté de ton le réalisateur a
dès lors qu'ils touchent nec la fiche
aussi dans un autre registre la série
satirique avec kenya maken ch un jeu de
mot sur la tournure il était une fois il
raconte les déboires politiques et
sociaux d'un pays imaginaire tout droit
sortie d'un conte on a voulu montrer une
histoire décalée des tunisiens comment
ils ont vécu comment elle pouvait vivre
et surtout critiqué la société actuelle
cette année dès les premiers épisodes la
série fait des clins d'oeil à la classe
politique rejetée par une partie de la
population ces dernières années ça
tourne autour d'un roi déchu qui essaye
de récupérer son trône ah mais ça va
être compliqué après tout ce qu'il a
fait mais je voulais parler de tout ce
qui s'est passé en tunisie elle sans
prendre parti avec personne rompre le
jeûne en regardant une série c'est un
rituel dans certaines familles comme
pour sarah et sa soeur est là elle
regarde comment tes critiques surtout
les séries qui parle de moeurs
le problème c'est que certains ne sont
pas fait mieux regarder en famille il
faut mettre moins deux ans quand même
unis nous sommes déjà tellement écrasé
par la situation économique et politique
il nous faudrait des choses plus légères
c'est dommage il n'y a pas de site comme
cette année à conques effet et comme
chaque année certains feuilletons font
déjà polémique comme celui qui regarde
sahara et sa soeur il aborde la
polygamie et le mariage coutumier
interdit en tunisie
on termine par du football la star du
football ivoirien didier drogba a
dévoilé lundi son programme pour
revitaliser le football ivoirien il
avait officialisé sa candidature à la
tête de la fédération nationale de
football au début du mois deux ans après
un premier échec lors ambert stecher
tout sourire didier drogba s'offre un
bain de foule avant de dévoiler son
programme s'il est élu le candidat à la
présidence de la fédération ivoirienne
de football promet une nouvelle ère pour
le ballon rond en côte d'ivoire
rapidement
la partie n'est pourtant pas gagnée pour
didier drogba l'ancien attaquant vedette
de l'olympique de marseille et de
chelsea fait face à deux poids lourds du
football ivoirien idriss diallo et sory
diabaté ancien haut responsable de la
fédération et s'il est de loin le plus
populaire sa candidature a déjà connu
son lot de controverses en 2020 il
n'avait pas obtenu les parrainages
nécessaires pour se présenter à
l'élection didier drogba avait alors
saisi la fifa qui avait mis la
fédération ivoirienne sous tutelle pour
son incapacité à organiser des élections
le feuilleton avait révélé la fragilité
des institutions sportives en côte
d'ivoire des institutions que didier
drogba compte réorganiser de fond en
comble s'il est élu samedi prochain il
pourrait ainsi emboîté le pas à une
autre star du football africain le
camerounais samuel eto'o élu président
de la fécafoot l'année dernier
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de paris direct avec
audrey racines
[Musique]